if you've ever tuned in to Fox on a
Sunday night and wondered whether you
are watching a long-running animated
sitcom or a cartoon prophecy you're not
alone here are some super freaky times
that The Simpsons has apparently
predicted the future The Simpsons began
life back in 1987 as a segment on The
Tracey Ullman Show one of the Fox
networks first shows that means a yellow
huge family has been a staple of the
network since the beginning and a search
frequently pokes fun at us corporate
overlords and we can't watch vodka do
neut chemical weapon plant in Syria the
1998 episode when you dish upon a star
found Homer working as a very annoying
personal assistant to the then married
couple of Alec Baldwin and Kim Basinger
who voiced themselves there are a number
of jokes at the expense of celebrities
and Hollywood in general thus allowing
this show another chance to slip in
another joke about Fox's business
practices there's a brief shot of the
entrance to the 20th Century Fox lot
which a sign says is a division of Walt
Disney Company nearly two decades later
the actual Walt Disney Company flushed
with cash from numerous successful
blockbuster flicks acquire 21st Century
Fox for a cool 71 point three billion
dollars so now Disney actually does own
Fox and The Simpsons
curling is a unique sport that involves
a careful pushing and sweeping of a
large stone on an ice rink it's been a
regular event at the Winter Olympics
since 1998 teams from cold snowy
countries like Canada Sweden and
Switzerland usually dominate the medal
count before 2018
Team USA it reached the medal podium
only once when the men's team went
bronze in 2006 the relative lack of
American presence in the sport added an
extra air of unlikelihood to the 2010
Olympics team Simpsons episode Boy Meets
curl in which Homer and Marge become a
mixed doubles curling duo for Team USA
they wind up winning the gold medal an
achievement that was improbable matched
by the real American men's curling team
in 2018
even weirder about this Simpsons
prediction is that the show foresaw
Mixed Doubles curling being an Olympic
event in the first place as it wasn't
part of the Winter Games lineup until
2018
judez the recurring character Fat Tony
is a big man in charge of Springfield's
legitimate businessman social club in
other words he's a local organized crime
boss he's been involved in a number of
shady and illegal activities and the
2002 episode Papa's got a brand new
badge involved one of his weirdest
schemes ever homers security company
spring shield busts Fat Tony for gluing
cotton balls on to ferrets with plans to
sell them to a pet store by passing them
off as far more expensive toy poodles
despite the unusual nature of this plot
it was remarkably similar to one a
real-life criminal actually attempted
with this latest arrest Springfield is
now free of crime
although overrun with ferrets in 2013 a
retiree visited the massive Lhasa Lada
Aldo bazaar in Buenos Aires Argentina
and purchased two poodles
he took his new pets to a veterinarian
for a check-up only for the doctor to
discover that they weren't poodles at
all they were ferrets given steroids to
a Pierre poodle sighs Bart and Lisa
loved the Itchy and Scratchy show the
cartoon segment on the Krusty the Klown
show that features the unspeakably gory
antics of a Tom and Jerry style cutter
Mouse in the 1992 episode itchy and
scratchy the movie that promotes his
other duo's feature film have to pull
out all the stops
so they install a billboard in
Springfield showing edgy using a movie
camera to chop off scratches head blood
spews out of the billboard with every
chop to the delights of drivers below
[Music]
then in 2008 when Quentin Tarantino's
Kill Bill Vol 1 a work almost as violent
as itchy and scratchy made its
Australian TV debut the network tv2
contacted the advertising firm Saatchi
and Saatchi to inform the public it did
so with a Billboard meets art
installation in which boomer Thurman's
carrot said the bride held a katana that
unleashed so much blood it exploded
beyond the printed panels and onto the
side of a building all over the street
and onto white cars parked below the
2010 episode elementary school musical
begins of Lisa and her friends watching
the announcement of that year's batch of
Nobel Prize winners they're more than a
little bit nerdy
they've all made predictions and printed
them out there Simpsons writers really
do their research for these scenes as
they aim to get the details just right
for even the briefest of sight-gags the
friend groups little chart lists 20
possible Nobel winners across five
categories and all of them are real
people and outstanding members of their
respective fields Milhouse has picked to
take home the big prize in economics is
banged our Holstrom a Finnish economist
and MIT faculty member amazingly they
usually hapless Milhouse got it right as
Holmstrom really did win the Nobel Prize
for economics in 2016
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]